[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض والتي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار
ملفات السعوديه والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين
اليوم
[موسيقى]
وكيف تتوقعوا قتال شريسا في لو كان
صندوق التنميه السياحي الى الان موال
تقريبا 25 مشروع في سنه ونصف فقط
وزير السياحه السعوديه يكشفوا عن تمويل
صندوق تنميه السياحيه في 25 مشروعا خلال
عام
صدور حكم ابتدائي بسجن ممارسه صحيه خمس
سنوات لاعتدائها على 11 رضيعا في السعوديه
ومن ملفاتنا المتنوعه في الرابعه كذلك
بداوا اعملي تفكيك خط انابيب تبلاين بشمال
السعوديه الرابعه تكشف تفاصيل المشروع
انطلاقه معرض بابنا للفنون الاسلاميه في
صاله الحجاج مطري جده بمشاركت نحو 40
فنانا
حياكم الله دعوه
الى التحلي بالصبر بشان قرار بلاده بارسال
دبابات اليوبارد اثنان الى المانيا
ان قرارا قريبا بشان هذا الموضوع سيتم
اتخاذه لكن يجب الوضع في الحسبان ان هذه
الدبابات تستخدم لاغراض الهجوميه وعلى
المانيا التفكير ماليا قبل ادخالها الحرب
اشار في ستوريوس الى انه من مصلحه المانيا
اتخاذ القرار بعنايه لانه قد يؤثر على امن
سكانها وموقفها وموقفها الواضح في انها لن
تدخل الحرب
اعلنتستونيا عن طرد السفير الروسي ردا على
قرار مماثل من موسكو اتخذته هذا الصباح
وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه كانت اعلى نت عن
تقليص المستوى الدبلوماسي بين روسيا
واستونيا الخارجيه الروسيه استدعت السفيره
الاستوني وسلامته احتجاجا شديدا ضد سلطات
الاستونيه كما طلبت السفير الاستوني
بمغادره البلاد في السابع من فبراير
قال وزير الخارجيه الروسيه الحرب اصبحت
حقيقيه ولم تعدنا وخلال مؤتمر الصحفي مع
نظيرته الجنوب افريقيا اتهم الى بروفا
الغربه بالاستعداد للحرب ضد روسيا منذ
فتره طويله لتدمير كل ما هو روسي على حد
تعبيره واضافه لم تتراجع عن اجراء مفاوضات
مع اوكرانيا متهما الغرب بتاجيلها كما دفع
عن اجراء روسيا منارات بحريه مشتركه مع
الصين وجنوب افريقيا
من العمليه العسكريه الخاصه وبحلول نهايه
مارس في اسطنبول على مبادئه لتسويه
الامريكيين والبريطانيين وبعد الاوروبيين
ابلغ اوكرانيا انه من السابق لاوانه
التوصلفاق
قالت المخابرات الاوكرانيه انها بتلحظ
وتغيرا في تكتيكات الروس العسكريه كما
قالت بانها تتوقع قتال شرسا في لوجان
سكودانتس في فبراير ومارس هذا واكد وزير
خارجيه اوكرانيا دي متروكوليبا على ان
بلاده بحاجه الى اتخاذ خطوه جريئه وحاسمه
لتامين انتصارها خلال العام الجاري واضاف
الوزير الاوكراني انه سيبحث في مجلس
العلاقات الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
عضويه بلاده في الاتحاد والمساعدات
العسكريه والدبابات وموضوع العقوبات ضد
روسيا بالاضافه الى صناعه الصواريخ
والمجال النووي
من كيف ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل حذيفه مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض كان لافتا هذا
التقرير اليوم من المخابرات
الاوكرانيه بشان سير المعارك بشان طريقه
ايضا حتى تفكير وتكتيكات الجيش الروسي في
المعارك الدائره في اوكرانيا كنا نتحدث عن
الشرق ان كنا نتحدث عن الجنوب
ما الذي
تجمله لنا من هذه التصريحات حتى الان
حذيفه
مساء الخير في الحقيقه طبعا اللافت في
الامر هو طريقه تكوين القوات التي تقاتل
القوات الروسيه التي تقاتل قالت
الاستخبارات العسكريه ان القوات الروسيه
عندما زحفت نحو العاصمه وقامت بالهجوم
الشامي من كل المناطق كانت تعمل بتكتيك
مختلف تماما الان التكتيك هي تعود الى
التكتيك التقليدي هو ان المشاه لديها
سيكون في الهجوم المتوقع القادم سيكون
لديها غطاء بالمدفعيه وكذلك بالطيران
الامر الذي لم تفعله في الاجياح الاول
للاراضي الاوكرانيه كما تقول الاستخبارات
العسكريه حتى طبيعه تكوين الكتائب
والالويه هي سوف تعود الى الطريق
التقليديه هذا خلاف من اتبعته في عمليه
الهجوم الاول في نحو الاراضي الاوكرانيه
من جميع الجهات ايضا تقول انه في الفتره
القادمه خلال اسبوعين او ثلاثه اسابيع سوف
يكون هنالك شده في المعارك اللاسيه في
منطقه الان تكثف قوات الاتحاد الروسي
جهودها للسيطره على هذه المناطق ايضا بيان
هيئه الاركان المشتركه اليوم يتحدث عن ان
القتال الاساسي هو في لوكا وفيدونيس مع
محاولات للتقدم في منطقه افديفكو وكذلك في
زاباروزا
ووصفها بالفاشله وانها لم يعني تاتي كلها
ولم تستطع القوات ان تتقدم للسيطره على
مناطق جديده ولكنها تواصل تكثيف هجماتها
في منطقه وذلك لاصول الى سيطره كامله
للحدود
الدفاع الروسيه
سيطره على همم هذه البلده همم كلاسين بولي
في دونتستك والقتال ربما كان عنيف في هذه
المنطقه خلال همم
الماضيه ما الذي تعنيه استراتيجيه هذه
المدينه
نعم في الحقيقه السيطره على كل بلده ااا
هو يعني تقدم جديد للقوات الروسيه او
خساره بالتاكيد للقوات الاوكرانيه الان
نحن نتحدث عن محاوله
احاطه كامله طبعا الدفاع الاوكرانيه قالت
واعترفت بان هنالك شبه الدائره او هنالك
قوس حول مدينه باخمود والان استراتيجيه
القوات الروسيه هي اقتطاع منطقه الاخرى
حتى عمليه الحصار الكامله لهذه المدينه
طبعا ايضا كل ما قضيه قتل المساحه كل ما
اصبحت اي عمليه الامداد في مرمى النيران
ومرمى مدفعيه القوات الروسيه وايضا القوات
الاستطلاع تستطيع ان ترى بوضوح اي عمليات
امداد بالذخائر او الاسلحه او الجنود او
قوافل القوات التي تدخل الى داخل مدينه
لذلك طبعا هنالك اهميه استراتيجيه لكل
شبرا الان بعد ان استطاع ان تسيطر على
معظم المناطق حول مدينه الان كل شيء كل
سوف تكسبه القوات الروسيه هو يقلل من فرص
دخول الامدادات الى القوات الاوكرانيه في
مدينه باكو وتذلك حديث يتداول في مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وفي الاعلام الاوكراني
حول ان الشركاء الغربيين الان ينصحونه
كييف بالتخلي عن هذه المدينه لان فاتوره
استمرانيه السيطر على هذه المدينه اصبحت
بيضه جدا في الوقت الذي تقوم القوات
الاوكرانيه الان بحسد الموارد كذلك القوات
الروسيه استعدادا لهجوم جديد من يعني كل
جانب يحاول ان يكون وقت الخريف او فصل
الخريف والربيع هو وقت ذروه القتال وهو
همم يعني امكانيه كسب همم الاراضي والهجوم
المتواصل
للصيطره وهذا وفي التوقيت الحالي الان
لذلك كل جانب لا يريد ان يدفع فاتوره
باهظه في السيطره على مناطق او بلديه لن
تكون ذات اهميه كبيره
مع كل همم التطورات والتفاصيل ايضا في هذه
الازمه الاوكرانيا الروسيه على كل حال
شكرا جزيلا لك من كيف العاصمه الاوكرانيه
مراسل العربيه حذيفه عدل
اعلنت او وافق الاتحاد الاوروبي في
اجتماعه المنعقد بالعاصمه البلجيكيه
بروكسل على فرض حزمه عقوبه جديده ضد دائره
مشيرا الى انها تستهدف قاده ايرانيين
متهمين باستخدام القمع ضد المتظاهرين وجدد
الاتحاد الاوروبي رفضه لاستخدام القوه
بشكل وحشيه من قبل السلطات الايرانيه ضد
المتظاهرين السلميين وهذا هو اعلنت النمسا
في ذات السياقنا العقوبات الاوروبيه
الجديده على ايران تشمل 37 شخصا
وفي هذا السياق قالت وزيره الخارجيه
الفرنسيه كاترين كلنا ان القمع في ايران
مستمر وفي مواجهه ذلك سيتم فرض عقوبات على
المسؤولين عنه مشيره في الوقت ذاته لان
جميع الخيارات المتعلقه بهذا الخصوص والده
[موسيقى]
وفي مواجهه هذا التصعيد سنقوم بمعقبه عدد
من المسؤولين عن هذا القمر
اعتبر رئيس البرلمان الايراني محمد باقر
انا العقوبات الامريكيه على طهران وموسكو
تشكل اكبر تهديدا في الوقت الراهن واضاف
باقر في مؤتمر صحفي مع رئيس مجلس وبروسيا
في الاستلاف فولدن ان الضغوط على البلدين
تتطلب العمل المشترك والتعامل الاستراتيجي
لتجاوز المرحله بدوره يعتبر بولدين ان
العقوبات الامريكيه تساهم في دفع العلاقه
بين البلدين قائلا ان الحاضر الذي تفرضه
امريكا وحلفائها سيدفع الى المزيد من
الانسجام والتعاوني بين موسكوتهران
اختفى العشرات من الاطفال الطالبي اللجوء
في بريطانيا
عن اختطافهم من قبل عصابات اجراميه صحيفه
الجارديان البريطانيه التي اوضحت كذلك بان
اختطاف الاطفال اللاجئين تم من فندق تديره
وزاره الداخليه رغم التحذير المتكرر لها
كما افاد المبلغون عن حالات الاختطاف ان
العمليه كانت على الشارع الرئيسي
وباستخدام سيارات مختلفه
اه من امام ذات الفندق الذي اختفى منه
الاطفال في مدينه برايتون ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو ومصطفى مساء
الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض يعني قصه ملفته طلعتنا بها صحيفه
الجارديان عن اختفاء الاطفال طالبه اللجوء
في بريطانيا ربما ايضا في هذا الفندق الذي
همم يظهر خلفك في الصوره ماذا لديك من
تفاصيل حول هذا الموضوع حتى الان
ابدا اولا نايف بان يشاهدت ااا يعني على
الاقل طفلين يعني ربما في حدود سن السادسه
عشر من العمر يعني خرجوا من هذا الفندق
وتوجهه الى الشاطئ على بعد تقريبا 100 100
متر ولا ربما ان القلق الذي يصور السلطات
المحليه وخاصه المجلس البلديه
حول الاخبار
او التحقيق الصحفي عن اختفاء العشرات من
هؤلاء الذين كانوا يقيمون في هذا الفندق
خلفي حسب
ما جاء في في هذا التحقيق ان همم مئه وسته
136 شخصا همم كانوا يقيمون في هذا الفندق
على مدى همم 18 شهرا همم
اختفوا لاسباب لا نعرفها بحسب يعني موظف
شركه لحمايه الاطفال تعاقدت مع وزاره
الداخليه بان بعضهم يعني تم اختطافهم ان
تاتي سيارات وهمم
ويتم نقلهم الى اماكن ربما بعيده عن مدينه
في جنوب شرقي انجلترا وبالتالي هذا همم
يعني همم اخبار يعني مثيره للغايه اذا
اصطدمت همم عامه الناس صدمت السياسيين
واولئك الذين يتابعون حقوق الطفل في
المملكه المتحده وبالتالي يعني
هذا الفندق
الذي يظهر خلفك في الصوره في مدينه هو
فندق تديره وزاره الداخليه فبالتالي هي
مسؤوله عن حمايه الاطفال داخل هذا الفندق
او حتى هي من امنت شركه شركه لحمايت هؤلاء
الاطفال بالتالي لا يوجد هناك اي مبرر اي
سبب لديهم مقنع لسبب هذا الاختفاء او على
الاقل بحث عن هؤلاء اطفال
عاده النيف يعني كل يعني هذه الفنادق التي
يتم حجزها من قبل وزاره الداخليه هي اا
يعني لامتلاك شركات واشخاص ومستثمرين ما
تفعله وزاره الداخليه هو انها ت- تحجز كل
الغرف في الفندق هناك مثلا بالنسبه لهذا
الفندق هناك ما يقارب من 60 غرفه فيه همم
يعني همم يعيش فيها هؤلاء همم
بالنسبه همم يعني الاداره ربما هناك همم
مندوبون تابعون لوزاره الداخليه وايضا
هيئات تتعلق بحمايه الطفل يكونون في في
هذا الفندق يجب تذكير بان عاده همم في
الفنادق التي يتم استخدامها للاجئين يجب
على كل شخص يطرق الفندق ان اا يسجل نفسه
انه ترك واي وبالضبط في اي ساعه وعند
العوده يجب ايضا ان يسجل اسمه مره ثانيه
توقيع بانه عاده الى الفندق هنا
انه هذه الفئات العمريه الصغيره التي يجب
حمايتها عندما تاتي الى المملكه المتحده
عبر طرق غير شرعيه وخاصه عبر القوارب سواء
يعني في همم في همم في مدينه دوفر او حتى
في مدن ساحليه اخرى يجب ان يحظوا برعايه
اجتماعيه عاده يجب ان لا تتعدى اقامتهم في
هذه الفنادق لاولائك همم الذين قتلوا
اعمارهم عن 18 عاما يجب نقله مباشره في
اقل من اسبوعين او سته عشر يوم تقريبا الى
هذه المراكز الاجتماعيه الخاصه بهم ولكن
يبدا ان في كثير من الحالات لم يتم الوفاء
بهذا التعاهد وان كانت الحكومه تعرف بانها
يجب ان تقدم كل ما يلزم لحمايه الطفل
اشكرك جزيلا شكرا على كل هذه المعلومات
من الفندق الذي اختفى منه الاطفال في
مدينه برايتون راس العربيه مصطفى شكرا لك
رابع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل ايضا
توقيع اتفاقيات باكثر من 10 مليارات ريال
على هامشي منتدى مستقبل العقار في الرياض
حياكم الله من جديد اعلانات نيابه العام
السعوديه عن ايقافي ممارسه صحيه قامت
بالاعتداء على 11 ربيعا كانت مؤتمنه عليه
وبالاطلاع على كاميرات المراقبه لغرفه
حضانه الرضع تبين قيام مذكورا بممارسه
عملها بقوه وعنف جسيمين على جسد احد الرضع
حيث كشفت اجراءات التحقيق امام المذكوره
بفعلها الشنيع مبرره ذلك بضغوطات العمل
كما اصدرت المحكمه المختصه حكمه
الابتدائيه بحق الممارسه الصحيه بالسجن
لمده خمس سنوات وغرامه قدرها 100.000 ريال
واشار مصدرا الى قيام نيابه الادعاء لعام
الاستئناف الحكم والمطالبه بتغليظ العقوبه
على المتهم نظيره شناعه جنايتها بحق الرضع
مسلوب الاراده
باشرت هيئه الرقابه ومكافحه الفساد في
السعوديه عدد من القضايا الجنائيه
والاداريه في 11 جهه حكوميه منها وزاره
الدفاع والداخليه والطاقه والعدل بعد ما
اجرت الهيئه اكثر من 2300 جوله رقبيه خلال
شهر نوفمبر الماضي توصلت الى التحقيق مع
ما يتجاوز 300 شخص وايقاف اكثر من 140
متورطا بقضايا الفساد نزاه كشفت ايضا عن
ابرز جرائم الفساد الماليه والاداريه
المرصده التي تضمنت الرشوه وغسل الاموال
بالاضافه الى استغلال النفوذ الوظيفي
بعد 73 عاما من انشائي خطي انابيب
التبلاين في منطقه الحدود الشماليه
السعوديه بدا العمل على تفكيك خط الانابيب
الذي لعب دورا محورين طوال 40 عاما في نقل
النفطي عبر الصحراء من بقيق شرق السعوديه
وحتى ميناء صيدا في لبنان
الذي سجل لك اول موقع لتراث الصناعي في
السعوديه توقف عن ضخ النفط منذ عام 1990
خطه انابيب التاب لاين روايه نجاح سعودي
يمتدت مع تدفق الذهب الاسود من بقيق شرق
السعوديه الى ميناء صيدا على البحر الابيض
المتوسط وصولا الى الاسواق العالميه حيث
لاعبه دورا محوريه بمد اوروبا بالطاقه على
مدى اربعه عقود قبل ان يتم ايقافه عن
الضغط عام 1990
من شخوص هذه الروايه محمد القبلان الذي
جرى من عمره 30 عاما في محيط جريان النفط
عبر هذا الانبوب
عام 1947 بامر من الملك عبد العزيز رحمه
الله وانا عملته في من عام
1957 بوظيفه
الاقتصاديه وكذلك ابعاده اجتماعيه لان
التابلين
وفرق المياه
والمستشفيات والمدارس
السكنيه بجوار التابرين وعاشت من رفاهيه
[موسيقى]
هذا المشروع الصناعي الذي ظل ممتدا من
ثياب على رمال الصحراء على مدى 73 عاما
بدات ارامكو حديثا بتفكيك اجزائه عدا
الواقعه قرب مدن محطات الدخل قديما كما
عالم شاخصه تحفظ مكانه اول موقع للتراث
الصناعي مسجل في السعوديه
[موسيقى]
اهميه كبيره
للاجيال القادمه
صنعتها السعوديه منتصر
باحد اكبر مشاريع نقل النفط عبر الصحراء
في العالم تتم وفق عمليات دقيقه وباليات
متطوره وباشراف مباشر من شركه ارامكو
من منطقه الحدود الشماليه
جزاعا ماصي العربيه
ومن جده ينضم الينا الرئيسيه لهيئه التراث
الدكتور جاسر الحربش دكتور جاسر مساء
الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض
في ما يخص طبعا
هيئه التراث دكتور جاسر عن قصه الازاله
اولا عن الاحتفاظ باجزاء من هذا الخط
التبلاين ما الذي يمكن ان نعرف عنه
الشوكه مره ثانيه على تواصلكم دائما انت
وسيلتنا للتواصل مع المجتمع وسيله
الرئيسيه حقيقه والتقرير مميز من الخزاع
واخونا ايضا الخبير محمد القبلاي يتحدث في
التقرير كلها قدمت راح الخلفيه الممتازه
اللي نحتاجها يمكن نوفره تقريبا بعض
المعلومات اللي بقولها ففعلا هو هو ال-
ال- المشروع الوطني مشروع ضخم وليس فقط
مشروع صناعي بالمناسبه احنا دائما نتحدث
عن هذا المشروع انه ايضا مشروع رؤيه
واستثمار لانه في ذلك الوقت المبكر عندما
يعني طبقت الفكره بقياده المؤسس معك عبد
العزيز رحمه الله الان همم بعد تسجيل همم
العنصر تاب لاين فيه موقع تراث احد عناصر
السجل التراث الصناعي الوطني وايضا ترشيح
وضمن ملف التراث الصناعي الوطني بشكل عام
التي يسجل في قائمه العامه
همم تم الاتفاق مع وزاره الطاقه وشركه
ارامكو على تفعيل عناصر كثير اكثر من 45
عنصر من ضمنها مثل ما ذكرتهم في التقرير
المميز من
حطتها الحمايه وحرم كبير من التايب لاين
سيبقى يحافظ عليه ال- ال- الاجمل من هذا
ان المواقع التي سيتم المحافظه عليها ليست
فقط ستبقى وتحمى بل انها ستفعل سيوضع في
موقع الان بدانا العمل فيه في مرحله
الدراسات والتصاميم في عرعر وان شاء الله
انه يعني
اشرح لها نقطه
ناخذ موقع مثلا موقع حاليا المحطه اللي
موجوده في عرعر الان نحن نعمل على تصاميم
مع مع شركه عالميه بمعالجه التراث الصناعي
العالميه ايضا مع الشركاء المحليين ان
يحول هذا المبنى الى مركز زوار يحكي قصه
التاب لاين قصه المواطنين المواطنين الذين
عملوا فيه واثر على حياتهم ايضا القصه قصه
التوثيق المخاطبات الوثائق كل ما لدى
الشركات والجهات والمشاركه سيعرض
يعني
التاب لاين لن يزال بكامله في اجزاء ستبقى
ضبط بالضبط بكل تاكيد وهذا هذا هو العمل
اللي استغرق تقريبا سنتين من بدايه العمل
مع الزملاء في وزاره الطاقه وشركه ارامكو
تم الاتفاق على مخطط كامل واعتماده من من
الخبر دوليين يعملون في اليونسكو وسيتم
التصرف بعض الاجزاء ولكن الجزء الاهم وهي
المحطات والعناصر اللي عددها 45 هو باقي
مثل ما قلت ليس باقي فقط كان حمايه صحيح
من وضع لوحات نضع بعض نقاط الحمايه لكن
المهم هو انه بفعل بيكون فيه يعني مثل ما
يعني مثل ما تروح الان انتم ضيوفك الحيه
طريف مركز زوار الجميل اللي موجود في
الدرعيه الضيوف اللي بيزورون مثلا الحدود
الشماليه بيكون احد نقاط الرئيسيه للزياره
عندهم ال- ال- مركز زوار خاصه
بكاملها ويكون شغاله على طول طول السنه
وليس مرتبط بفعاليه
احنا طبعا 45 حافظنا عليها لكن احنا نتحدث
عن يعني الرؤيه القريبه القريبه يعني سنه
سنتين القادمه يتحدث عن خمس مواقع ان شاء
الله للمنطقه الشرقيه نصيب وفي منطقه حدود
الشماليه نصيب والاهم من هذا انها تقدم
بشكل جاذب يحكي القصه يحكي اثر هذا
المشروع على الضخم وفي وثائق ضخمه جدا
يعني الزملاء فيها في وزاره الطاقه يعني
بلغونا عنكم تحت تصرفنا الموضوع الصور بعض
مقاطع الفيديو الوثائق التي تنشر لاول مره
ايضا التراث المحكي يعني انتم يعني
تقريركم مميز وصلت الاحد اهم مصادر الطره
المحكمه محمد القبلان وهناك تسجيلات هناك
منهم على قيد الحياه الله يرحمه لكن كل
عملنا الان في المشروع الذي يعمل بشراكه
معي اماره المنطقه امانه المنطقه الحدود
الشماليه ومع وزاره الطاقه من جهه وشركه
ارامكو وباقي الشركان المحليين طبعا
عليها من وزاره الطاقه
سواء انشاء هذه
ال- ال- المحطه او كيف كانت تعمل
والمشاركين فيها او الصوره يعني او
المستندات حتى الرسميه ستكون في هذه
المواقع الخمسه اللي ذكرتها للزوار منتهى
فقط اي اي اي يعني وثيقه او صوره او فيديو
يعني هينا اجراءات النظاميه لعرضه فسيعرض
الزملاء متعاونيه مجزره الطاقه وكل
الشركاء وانا متاكد حتى للاهاليوم يعني
لديهم عدد من الوثائق اللي تشرفنا احنا
بعرضها ونضع عليها اسمه من هذه الوثيقه
قدمت من المواطن او المواطنه بالاسم
المحدد مثل ما نعمل احنا في كل همم يعني
اسالي بداراتنا التراث الثقافي دائما كلنا
يا اخوي نايف ومع الزملاء في نشاه الرابعه
انشانا التراث الثقافي هو شان لي شان هيئه
حكوميه فقط هو شان مجتمع شان شركاء شهر
رساله نحن نوصلها ونشاركم معنا يعني فانا
اجتها فرصه يعني تقريركم هذا يعطينا فرصه
اننا ندعو مره ثانيه انه اذا في يعني جهه
او او فرد ااا او مؤسسه او او قطاع خاص
قطاع عام قطاع الربحي عنده معلومات او
عنده رغبه او عنده قدره انه يشارك في
المشروع العظيم هذا تشرفنا بالعمل فيه من
خلال المنظومه وزاره الثقافه هيئه التراث
بالمناسبه يمكن انا نسيت اقول شيء مهم انه
يوجد جمعيه اسست جمعيه للتراث الصناعي
الان نحن نعمل على اعاده تشكيله
ايضا بعض
المواقع الهامه التي كانت شاهد على همم
التنميه الصناعيه التي بدات بالمملكه
العربيه السعوديه
شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا الله يسلمك شكرا
انطلقت اليوم نسخه الثانيه لمنتدى مستقبل
العقار في العاصمه الرياض حيث تم توقيع
اتفاقيات باكثر من 10 ملارات ريال لا
تنعقاد المنتدى بالتزامن مع البدء بسريان
نظام الوساطه العقاريه التي تعد من ابرز
الممكنات لتطوير القطاع العقاري وحكمته
ويستمر المنتدى لمده ثلاثه ايام ويشارك
فيه اكثر من 30 دوله ومئه متحدث يمثلون
القطاعين العام والخاص بجانب مشاركه
اقتصاديين ومستثمرين في قطاع العقار محليا
وعالميه
خلال المنتدى كشفه وزير السياحه احمد
الخطيب عن تمويل لصندوق التنميه السياحي ل
25 مشروعا في عام ونصف بقيمه 15 مليار
ريال مضيفا ان ذلك يعد احد مستدفات قطاع
السياحه لاضافه حوالي 70 الى 80 مليار
دولار للاقتصاد السعودي بحلول عام 2030
في بعض الدول
وصل التمثيل القطاع في
اجمال الناتج المحلي الى 15% مثل فرنسا
واسبانيا احنا القطاع بدانا في 2019 قبل
الازمه بثلاثه في المئه
وصلنا الى 4% بنهايه العام الماضي
وهدفنا ان شاء الله لانه نوصل الى
10% اللي هو المتوسط العالمي بحلول عام
2030 وهذا يعني
اضافه همم تقريبا همم 70 الى 80 مليار
دولار الى
اجمال الناتج المحلي في الاقتصاد السعودي
همم اضافه الى ذلك اضافه
فرص وظيفيه كثيره لانه يعتبر القطاع من
اهم القطاعات في العالم
لخلق الوظائف صندوق التنميه السياحي الى
الان موال تقريبا 25 مشروع في سنه ونصف
فقط
بقيمه 15 مليار
ويوصل التمويل الى 60% ونتحالف مع البنوك
الاخ طارق هنا بنك الرياض دخلنا معكم في
طارق في كذا مشروع مع صندوق التنميه
السياحي
فالتحالف هذا مع البنوك مكه المستثمرين
انه يجي يحط 30 40% من عنده والباقي تمويل
ب- اا تكلفه همم منافسه بمده سداد طويله
يعني جميع التسهيلات وضعناها على شان
القطاع الخاص يساهم في النهضه اللي يشهدها
هذا القطار
بدوره شدد بندر الخريف وزير الصناعه
والثروه المعدنيه على اهميه القطاع
العقاري في دعم الطلب على المنتجات
الصناعيه حيثما مات الصناعات المرتبطه
بالتشييد والبناء بنسبه تجاوزت 50% خلال 5
اعوام
اهم
ميزه تميز بالنسبه لنا على الاقل ننظر
القطاع هو انها محرك اساسي للطلب ولاحظنا
النمور الكبير في الفتره الاخيره همم فيما
يتعلق بالصناعات المرتبطه بقطاع البناء
والتشييد بالذات يمكن فيه نمو زاد عن 50%
في الفتره الاخيره فقط من عام 2018 الى
اليوم في عدد المصانع التي همم انشات لهذا
القطاع من جانب الاخر همم وجود قطاع
في نمو مستدام يحفز ليس فقط على الاستثمار
وانما ايضا يحفز على التطوير والابداع
ولذلك نحنا نعمل مع منظومه وزاره الشؤون
البلديه والاسكان على ايضا مساعده ال هذا
القطاع
بتبني
التقنيات حديثه للبناء بحيث يكون البناء
اسرع بحيث يكون هناك همم محاوله لتحويل
معظم النشاط البناء والتشييد الى الصناعه
بدل ما يكون في الموقع ويمكن المعاليه من
الداعمين بل هما اصحاب يمكن المبادره
واليوم الحمد لله في مبادره مشتركه ما بين
وزاره البلديه والاسكان ما بين منظومه
الصناعه وممثله في الصندوق الصناعي لتمويل
مشاريع صناعيه التي تركز على تقنيات
البناء
هذا في حد ذاته طبعا سيكون له اثر مباشره
على
الاقتصادنا واثر مباشر على
تنفيذ مشاريع بشكل عام في قطاعه الشيد
والبناء وبالذات الاسكان بسرعه اكبر
وتكلفه اقل وبجوده باذن الله اعلى
كشف مدير الامن العام في السعوديه الفريق
محمد البسام يعني العملي على تطوير منصه
كلنا من كما كشف عن تزويد الدوريات
الامنيه بتقنيات الحديثه تسهم في اكتشاف
المطلوبين خلال السيره
او كلنا امن
ندرك تماما انه البلاغ هو يعتبر بالنسبه
لنا في الامن من من من من من من من الامور
الهامه
لذلك اليوم كلنا امن تحت التطوير
ووستقبل ان شاء الله بلاغات 17 عن طريق
الامن راح يكون فيه سلسه من الاجراءات
يقدر الان انه همم المبلغ الذي يرفع جميع
البيانات عن طريق الامر واحنا ممكن ان شاء
الله توظيف هذا التقنيه همم بالقريب
العاجل باذن الله الدوريات الامنيه اليوم
احنا ايضا في شراكه مع شركه علم همم
لتوفير عدد كبير من الانظمه التقنيه ايضا
في همم الدوريه بحيث ان تكون الدوريه هي
ايضا كامله بجميع متطلبات العمل الامني
همم وممكن يعني الدوريه تكتشف بعض
المطربين في الشارع وتحلل جميع البيانات
من خلال السياره الدوريه بشكل مباشر وان
شاء الله نطلقها يعني تقريبا يمكن
الاحتمال قبل الحج
اصل وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان قرارا بتعيني ثرى السيد وكيلا
للوزاره للشؤون الدبلوماسيه العامه لتكون
اول امراه سعوديه تشتغل هذا المنصب وكانت
السيده ساره السيد قد شغلت منصبه مديره
عامه للتعاون الدولي في الوزاره لمده
ثلاثه اعوام او مديره اقليميه في مستشفى
الامريكي لمده عامين بالاضافه الى عملها
في منصب وكيله مساعده مكلفه لوزاره الصحه
للتعاون الدولي بين عامين 2019 و22
اهلت الخطوط الحديديه ساره عبر المعهد
السعودي التقني للخطوط الحديديه 32 قائده
لقطار الحرمين السريع التي بشرنا العمل
عقب تدريبهن من قبل خبراء في المعهد على
مدى 14 شهرا بين التدريب النظري والعملي
التفاصيل مع زميل سلطان السلمي
[موسيقى]
من اداره الاعمال
الى قمره القياده في قطار الحرمين السريع
والذي يحمل على متنه 417 راكبا تسافر
رتيلان الجار بالركاب والمعتمرين من مكه
الى المدينه مرورا بجده بعد ان اجتازت 220
ساعه من التدريب العملي وسجلت فصلا من
طموحها بعد ان بدات كبائعه لتذاكر في هذه
المحطه قبل ان تصبح رمانه وهو
حلمها الجديد
[موسيقى]
لما كنت اشوف قائدين القطار يعني مره كان
يشدن الموضوع انه كيف كانوا يتعاملوا مع
حجاج بيت الله الحرام والمعتمرين
فقدت ليش لا يعني يوم من الايام ما اكون
في نفس مكانهم ايش تس في فتره التدريب
العملي قرابه 220 ساعه لقياده القطار
تدربت من خلالها على انظمه الامن والسلامه
وكل ما يخص قمره القياده في القطار
وتدربنا ايضا على فرضيات مختلفه همم حتى
نختم الركاب بافضل وسيمه ممكنه
[موسيقى]
رتيله وراني وغيرهما من الفتيات السعوديات
فتحت لهم الخطوط الحديديه المجاله لقياده
القطارات للمره الاولى بعد ان تلقوا
التدريب والتاهيل عبر المعهد السعودي
التقني للخطوط الحديديه لمده 14 شهرا حيث
تلقوا تدريبات متقدمه في مختلف مهارات
قياده القطارات
417 راكب غير الطاقه من المتواجد على
الرحله
ففي خوف من
المسؤوليه لكن الحمد لله الرحله كانت سلسه
تماما في نفس الوقت كان في رغبه في كده
حماس اني اخذ هذه التجربه لاول مره
جئنا ضمن الدفعه الاولى من قائدات قطار
الحرمين والذي انتهى بتخريج اثنتين
وثلاثين قائده قطار في خطوه الاولى
ينتظروا ان تتبعها خطوات اخرى لتمكين
الفتيات في قطاع النقل من جده سلطان
السلمي العربيه
رابع مستمره وفي بعد قليل
انطلاقه معرض لبناء الفنون الاسلاميه في
صاله الحجاج في مطار جده بمشاركه نحوي 40
فنانه
حياكم الله دشنت مؤسسه بناء الدرعيه معرض
الفنون الاسلاميه في صاله الحجاج في مطار
الملك عبد العزيز في جده حيث يعد بنادي
الفنون الاسلاميه الذي ياتي تحت شعار اول
بيت ويستمر حتى الثالث والعشرين من ابريل
يعد منصه تعكس تجربه الحجاج القادمين من
حول العالم من خلال التامل في تنوع
التجربه الاسلاميه ويتضمن اعمال نحو 40
فنانا بمجموع اعمال تصل الى ما يقاربوا
280 قطعه اثريه معاره من مؤسسات المحليه
ودوليه
من مبنى صاله الحجاج في مطار الملك عبد
العزيز بجده ينضم ولينا مراسل العربيه
السلطان السلمي السلطان مساء الخير مرحبا
بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض نريد
لوحه جوله ايضا في
هذا البناءلي بنالي للفنون الاسلاميه في
جده
قناه العربيه قبل ان نبدا جولتنا داخل
معرض بناء للفنون الاسلاميه اريد ان كافه
انظار العالم او المهتمين بالثقافه
والفنون والفن المعاصر وبالفن الاسلامي
تحديدا تتجه نحو جده وتحديدا لمعرض بناني
للفنون الاسلاميه هذا المعرض الذي سوف
يستمر لثلاثه اشهر يقام للمره الاولى في
مدينه جده وقام اقيم قبل ذلك في مدينه
الرياض اليوم هذه هو اليوم الاول لهذا
المرض الذي يضم خمسه معارض جناحين وتفاصيل
كبرى ممكن زميلنا محمود يعطينا جوله
للمكان واريد ارحب بضيفه الان الساده
فريده الحسيني مديره معرض همم بنالي
للفنون الاسلاميه بدايه ماذا يميز معرض
بنادي الفنون الاسلاميه والمختلف عن بقيه
المعارض الاسلامي
والله المعرض عندي يمتاز بانه يجمع بين
القطاع التاريخيه والقطع الفن المعاصر
وجمعنا اجمل التحف واجمل على الاعمال
الفنيه من كل انحاء العالم عندنا تحف جايه
من اليونان عندنا تحف جايه من الكويت ومصر
ومن المتاحف تركيا وفي
المانيا بالاضافه الى الفنانين عندنا من
افضل الفنانين السعوديين والسعوديات
الشباب والبنات وعندنا ايضا الفنانين من
كنا كل انحاء العالم جنوب افريقيا من همم
العالم العربي مصر والمغرب وكثير من الدول
في ما يتعلق بانه اليوم خمس معارض كل
معارض يتكلم على مرحله زمنيه معينه او
فكره معينه يرويها للمتابعه او للزائر
مختلفات فعندنا قسم رئيس اللي هو قسم اول
بيت سموه القيمين الفنيين تكلم في جزئين
عن فكره القبله اللي هي اللي تربط بين
العالم الاسلامي كله بمكه والمدينه وفي
عندنا القسم الخارجي اللي اسمها هيجره
اللي هي تجمع بين الاعمال الفنيه اللي
تربط بين فكره ال- اا المجتمعات الاسلاميه
حول العالم بالاضافه لذلك عندنا معرض
المداره اللي احنا فيه حاليا اللي يجمع
مشاركات من مختلف الدول عندنا تقريبا 13
دوله مشاركها منها اوزباكستان و طبعا
الكويت على الصباح مجموعه ال صباح التراث
الفني همم وجمعنا فيها اكثر من 300 قطعه
تاريخيه اليوم شفت عدد كبير من المتهمين
لهذه الفنون قادمين من مختلف الدول العالم
كزوار وسياح لهذا المعرض المهم بس باتحدث
اليوم خمسه معارض جناحين مكه وجناح اخر
للمدينه كم عدد المشاركين من الفنانين
وعدد القطع اللي موجوده في المعرض
والهدف الرئيسيه من هذا المعرض
والله من ناحيه الفنانين عندنا تقريبا 40
فوق ال 50 فنان وشارك التحف عندنا اكثر من
500 تحفه فنيه على المساحه بالكامل ومنها
قطع ما قد تعرضت من قبل اشياء تحف فنيه
يعني اصلا هي موجوده في المملكه في مؤسسات
في المملكه ما قد شافت ما قد تعرضت وعندنا
ايضا مشاركات يعني فعلا جذابه من
الاعمال الفنيه للمعاصره على السريع او
عجاله رسالتكم في هذا المعرض
رسالتنا اننا نربط ان نوثق العلاقات بيننا
وبين العالم الاسلامي وعشان كده ركزنا على
فكره اول البيت والعلاقه بين المسلمين بين
مكه والمكرمه والمدينه المنوره شكرا لك
كان معنا همم استاذه فريده الحسيني مديره
معرض بنالي الفنون الاسلاميه هذا المرض
اللي يشهد عدد او اقبال كبير من قبل
الزوار والمهتمين في جده ومن خارج
السعوديه كاميرا للهواتف والصفيين وكل
المهتمين المؤرخين والاكاديميين يوثقون
هذا المعرض المهم الذي يروي تفاصيل او
قطعه تعود الى الاف السنين نعم
ما تبقى لديك كثير من الوقت المبنى صاله
الحجاج في مطار الملك عبد العزيز بجده
مراسل العربيه السلطان السلمي شكرا يا
سلطان خلال هذه الفتره يمكن مشاهدته كوكب
المشتري ونجم الشعره ونجم السيل بالعين
المجرد التفاصيل مع خالد الزعت في تقويم
[موسيقى]
اكبر كواكب المجموعه الشمسيه المشتري
والمع نجوم السماء اشعره وانه هو رب شعره
واشهرها نجم سهيل وسهيل كنجمه الحب في
اللون وقلب المحب في الخفقان واجمل ما
بالكون القمر وهذه الثلاث المشتري الشعره
سهيل سنشاهدها بالعين المجرده طوال هذه
الليالي المشتري بالجهه الغربيه والشعره
فوق الراس واسهيل بالجهه الجنوبيه كشفت
ثلاث ذوائم من شعرها في ليله فارط ليالي
اربعه واستقبلت قمر السماء بوجهه فارتني
القمرين في وقت
معا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وكل ليله من هذه الليالي يقترب كوكب
المشتري من القمر واقرب مسافه بينهما
يسميه العرب بالاقتران فالجميل سيقترن مع
الكوكب الكبير المشتري اكبر من الارض ب
1200 مره والقمر اصغر من الارض ب 40 مرات
فلو جمعتم جمال الكون اجمعه في شخص اخرى
وقد جاءت هنا لكنت كالصخره الصماء عاطفه
وقلت هذا الجمال
ليس يعنيني
[موسيقى]
ختام الرابع بابرز عناوينها
موسكو تعلن سيطره على بلدتي كاس امبولي
وكيف تتوقع قتالا شرسه في لوغان سكودانت
التنميه
الصندوق التنميه السياحيه ل 25 مشروعا
خلال عام
صدور حكم الابتدائيه بسجن ممارسه صحيه خمس
سنوات لاعتدائها على 11 رضيعا في السعوديه
بداوا عمل لتبكيكي خطي انابيب التاب لاين
شمال السعوديه الرابعه تكشف تفاصيل
المشروعه
تمام انطلاق معرض بنا للفنون الاسلاميه في
صاله الحجاج في مطار جده بمشاركه 40 فنانه
في رعايه
[موسيقى]